maximum problems is actually call if
there's no topic called max we promise
actually other applications of
differentiation the way I think about it
it's an extension on all the cactus
would be doing finding station points
finding 20 points but we're sort of
applying it to problem solving scenarios
okay so what you're mostly going to find
in these kinds of this topic basically
is right then you've got some wine and
some X noodle is what they are they're
just random letters okay you're gonna
get scenarios like there's the
temperature of a place or there's a
height of a ball or there's the area of
a piece of paper or the volume of a box
okay so although these are going to be
cashed in very concrete terms okay and
so for that reason you also need to do
some more thinking like it's not just
the equation to you you bash it down
you're different yet to find a number
you've actually got to figure out a
scenario beans okay
so we'll get to that in a second now all
I'm gonna cover in this introduction is
how do you what's the basic approach to
a maximum problem and how does it apply
how does it relate to differentiation
okay
so what I'd like you to jump down first
is I really actually give you the
wording of the question we'll talk
through it okay is passing by her
so we're going to be thinking about
distances because it's distances you
might think we would usually say you
know let distance be D or something like
that but I'm actually gonna say rather D
because then we're going to have like D
D on DT which is a bit confusing so I'm
going to call P for position okay so
it's position yeah could you just finish
by saying it's just this yeah I mean
it's just really in some ways well
because like s for displacement anyway
this musician relative is given by the
equation
okay its position relative to dis given
by the equation
Oh what now because this is a it's a
problem solving theory right
usually we're used to derivatives and
all that kind of thing having no units
on them but these obviously you have to
have units okay so let's say P is in
thousands of kilometers okay so if P was
one okay that means the comment is a
thousand kilometers away
here's two 2000 called was away etcetera
okay
and T okay might be hours minutes
seconds doesn't matter as long as you
pay attention to what they are so the
question is what is the closest the
comment reaches pushes to us and when
does it happen
okay now this is pretty standard for a
maximum problem okay you've got your
scenario they'll give you some kind of
equation which tells you about what
governs this scenario and then they'll
pose you a question based on that okay
and what our job is is to interpret this
and think about okay what mats am I
gonna have to do to solve it yeah that's
right so I'm starting off nice and
simple okay and we're even saying with a
really simple equation as well we'll get
into the complexity this time class
right now
how are we gonna do this my first advice
before we actually apply Eddie you know
actually in calculus to it is can we
just get a look at what this thing is
doing well what's it behaving like okay
so this thing here we can graph this
okay and that'll show us how this
kammath behaving and then we can start
to apply problem-solving to it okay some
people will start doing the numbers
first in the equations but I think this
way will guide what kind of things you
do so P equals T squared minus 2t plus 4
we can graph this to work out what it
looks like as a graph say it again axis
okay now before I go on usually we used
to a wine and x-axis right but I don't
have Y's or X's here so P is gonna be my
vertical axis P so that's the distance
and he's gonna be my horizontal axis
yeah I will say for this question and
this is most often the case that T is
specified it must be positive but
sometimes it's not okay for instance the
question might say T equals 0 is 12 noon
12 noon right and therefore negative
values for T are meaningful right like T
is minus 5 might be like 7 a.m. or
something like that ok so just watch out
this is the UK so it's not always right
now because it's the case here
I'm just controlling a positive side of
the T axis that is such a not straight
line
I'll fix it there's a grid on this board
I don't know if you can see it from
where you are but it makes it really own
faith it's quite thing isn't it okay so
there's my my pain my t axis now before
I do anything I already know pick up he
intercept is 4 but what does the rest of
it look like hey you gonna work it out
well is it's gonna be concave up ok so I
can see that because I've got positive
coefficient of T but what else do I want
to know about it ok intercept is the
first plating place to go okay however
however you look at it and you're like
okay you don't have to do this every
time but yeah I'm sort of I've thought
of this question in months so I already
know you can do it what kind of
intercept you're gonna have by looking
at the discriminant right b squared
minus 4ac now it looks to be like 4
minus 16 minus 12 okay so if the
discriminant no x-intercepts okay so
it's called a bar I don't even know
where the axis of symmetry is okay so
this is good right I don't have any
roots so how else am I gonna work out
what this looks like
I could sub eval use what's an important
feature of the graph okay the vertex
that'll be useful for and in fact not
just is it useful to know what it looks
like but it's kind of useful for the
questions as well how do you work out
the vertex axis of symmetry so the axis
is minus B on to a minus B on to a so
that's minus minus 2 so positive 2 on 2
X 2 over 2 that's 1 okay so there's my x
value so therefore the Y value for that
plug it in 1 minus 2 plus 4
one minus two plus four sounds like
three one three so that means that sorry
you caught me old habits die hard don't
they
okay P is sure enough that's three okay
so there's my vertex
I already knew it was concave up so this
is what it looks like and as Daniel
pointed out that's probably a good thing
because if pity equals to zero the
position that means the comments gonna
hit us okay and it did say it's possible
but okay so at the top you start
measuring it's that far away 4,000
points it's gonna get close off the
quizzes it gets his 3,000 and then it's
just gonna Nick off and we'll never see
it again now that's the answer to the
question right what is the closest to
call it reaches to earth answer 3000
kilometers where does this happen after
one day okay so I actually know what my
answer is going into this but it's not
enough to actually just say therefore
okay and it doesn't say that right we've
got to use calculus to prove it